At a preview event for the Consumer Electronics Show in Las Vegas,...
...new tech was flying, leaping and lighting up.
The LG G Flex offers a glimpse of the shape of smartphones to come: curves.
So it's the world's first curved, flexible smartphone.
If you're holding it to your face, it contours your face,...
...brings that mic a little bit closer to you, giving you a better sound experience.
Also, it fits in the palm of your hand.
The possibilities of what we can do with our smartphones continue to grow.
This is the Jumping Sumo which can be controlled from your mobile phone or tablet.
It may be a small robot but it's robust and can leap two and a half feet into the air.
And like a cat that always lands on its feet, the Sumo always lands on its wheels.
The mobile QWERTY turns the traditional keyboard on end.
A full QWERTY keyboard that's been split and rotated...
...so that I've still got it underneath both hands.
TREWGrip is a handheld Bluetooth mouse and keyboard.
I don't need to find a surface where I can use my keyboard.
Wearable tech is a star attraction this year.
Designed for athletes, the Reebok CHECKLIGHT is a sensor device that fits into a skullcap...
...and detects impact and possible head injuries.
It's a three-light LED system.
It's a green for on and functioning,...
...yellow for moderate impact and red for more severe.
There are plenty of wearables that tell you how active you are.
June does something different.
It tracks your exposure to the sun, and depending on your skin type,...
...it'll tell you when to get out of the sun and when to break out the sunscreen.